ااا الى ملفا اخر وتحديدا الى افغانستان
عارضات ازياء بلاستيكيه برؤوس مغطاه
باكياس سوداء او ملونه يشهد غريب ومخيف في
الوقت نفسه سيطر على واجهات محلات الازياء
في كابول ففي خانه قمع حريات النساء ارادت
حركه طالبان ازالت هذه العارضات من نوافذ
المتاجر او قطع راس العارضه تماما اجراء
احدهما اسوا من الاخر بعض بائعي الملابس
امتفلوا للتعليمات لكنها اخرين رفضوا ذلك
متضرعين بحدب امكانيه عرض الملابس بشكل
صحيح او اتلاف عارضات الازياء التي تعتبر
باهضه الثمن بعد هذه الشكاوى طالبان عدلت
القرار وسامحت لاصحاب المتاجر بتغطيات
رؤوس العارضات بالازياء للموازنه بين طاعه
الحركه ومحاوله جذب العملاء اي عارضات
ملثمات موافقه صحيفه الشرق الاوسط فبدل من
قطع رؤوس العارضات في المحاله التجاريه
لفوها باكياس همم سوداء قماشيه او من
البلاستيك بعض التجار تحايلوا على الاجراء
بتغطيه رؤوس عارضات الازياء باكياس مصمه
من نفس ماده الفساتين الاساسيه حركه
مشابهه لكمامات صممت من خامات الالبسه
والتي انتجت خلال جائعات كورونا